[Music]  Super Bowl 52 brought out a who's who of  ælis stars as the Philadelphia Eagles  took on the New England Patriots and  ultimately reigned victorious like  Shelton and Gwen Stefani made it a  family weekend the couple attended the  big game with Gwen's three sons Apollo  Kingston and Zuma with Gwen documenting  all the adorable moments on her  Instagram story Jennifer Lopez and Alex  Rodriguez also attended they suited up  in their chicest warmest attire  Bradley Cooper a Philadelphia native  showed off his spirit alongside his love  model Irina Shayk amazing life dream the  pair posed for a photo with fellow  Eagles supporters miles teller and  fiance Kelly Sperry miles clearly  thrilled to see his team win and it was  the ultimate date night for Justin  Timberlake and Jessica Biel after JT  crushed the Pepsi halftime show he  shared this pic to Instagram watching  the game and eating snacks with his  proud wife